icó del pol pot couture street x another
player à sky
knows why this idea the balcony we deny
solemn takes water portuguese
to american samba we have not known
recipe in mauá shelley detail and in
general from unesco friend of the queen so
that companions
like this  but such and such a shift butt
no
I'm not afraid it's jeans to god martins
pinto martins matheus sing martin
[Music]
he lays down
[Applause]
[Music]
I still thought 'don't abc you is
the reason
who am I and  does not favor the hubble
[Music]
that's it
tel
[Music]
this team
[Applause]
here too
me who I'm that is gedo elza gang
has this keep your pate maternal
[Applause]
get to
the year
is now good or not
now hitachi arrives
[Applause]
oh oh oh the mother and that's it I
have it's gedo's challenge that is the challenge of
mateus
a tap
a oi was in the i key
[Music]